quelques heures plus tard yannick jadot
comme eric zemmour vote également à
paris à l'autre bout de la france à
marseille où il est élu en tant que
député jean-luc mélenchon glisse lui
aussi son bulletin dans l'urne
les français ont rendez vous avec les
urnes pour le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle roussel à
saint-amand-les-eaux nicolas dupont
aignan a hier jean lassalle à lourdios
ichère ou encore nathalie arthaud à
pantin je vais rappeler quand même les
règles et aux cas où avant d'atr on ne
les entend pas on ne les écoute pas ces
20 heures emmanuel macron et marine le
pen sont qualifiés pour le second tour
avec respectivement vous le voyez 28,6
pour cent le peuple français s'est
exprimé et me fait l'honneur d'être
qualifiés au second tour face au
président sortant
par eric zemmour 6,8 pour cent des voix
yannick jadot ensuite avec 4,6 pour cent
des voix et valérie pécresse 4,6
également nous devons tirer les
conséquences cette campagne n'a pas
fonctionné ni sur le fond ni sur
l'adéquation entre notre candidate et le
peuple de france ou députés sont tous
des élus locaux ou originaires de
territoires là où vous avez aujourd'hui
une majorité je le dis amicalement de
godillots les marcheurs c'est des béni
oui oui qui s'excuse toutes les deux
minutes d'exister par rapport à ce que
dit le président de la république
sortant je connais votre colère ne vous
abandonnez pas à ce qu'elle vienne à
vous faire commettre des erreurs qui
serait
définitivement irréparable pour que la
france ne bascule pas dans la haine de
tous contre tous je vous appelle avec
gravité a voté le 24 avril prochain
contre l'extrême droite de marine le pen
je répète parce que des fois il arrive
que même quand je dis les choses c'est
comme si je ne les avais pas dit
alors je recommence à cet endroit du
film
il ne faut pas donner sol voir madame le
pen
notre vote ne vaut pas caution pour sa
responsabilité dans la fracturation du
pays à force d'inaction climatique de
déni social de conformisme et de mépris
démocratique jamais nous ne banalise
rond l'extrême droite et ses idées c'est
pourquoi
j'appelle ce soir à battre l'extrême
droite à la mettre en échec on se
servant du sol il sera à sa disposition
je veux ici
saluer leur clarté à l'égard de
l'extrême droite et pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas voté pour
emmanuel macron ont bien sûr vocation à
rejoindre ce rassemblement
et malgré les profondes divergences que
j'ai martelé tout au long de la campagne
je voterai en conscience emmanuel macron
pour empêcher l'arrivée au pouvoir de
marine le pen et le chaos qui en
résulterait un des positions différentes
gelé moi j'ai toujours eu les mêmes
positions je les dis en novembre donc
j'ai une constance et je ne vais pas
changer les vôtres et marine le pen y
aller c'est aussi ça la ligne politique
mon vote m'appartient et nous verrons
dans les jours qui vit qui viennent ce
que ce qu'il en sera emmanuel macron et
le premier adversaire il est le
président de l'immigration massive il
prison à sécurité est prise dans l'ain
désindustrialisation du du déclassement
de la france sur le plan diplomatique
donc il n'y a pas d'hésitation à avoir
un homme qui n'a pas dit un mot
d'identité de sécurité d'immigration
pendant sa campagne et qui fera donc
pire s'ils étaient réels je ne me
tromperai pas d'adversaires c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'appelle mes
électeurs à voter pour marine le pen
car ne nous trompons pas
rien n'est joué et le débat que nous
aurons dans les quinze jours à venir est
décisif pour notre pays et pour l'europe